[Applause]
hey what's up lab Bible it is Tom
Molyneux and I'm going to play slack
Wars what happens next
first impressions so let's go yeah cuz
that's what they do there's a chicken Oh
ostrich no that was actually a better
bird it's a bird obviously okay well
there's little wings cuz you mean your
wings are those little bit small bird a
crow okay here we go ah okay here we go
this licorice is that what you call this
is this the English one nein no that's
disgusting I'm not the only thing here
that is disgusting I can't swear can I
that's gusting I used to love toxic
waste you ever have so many toxic wastes
that you can't eat anything for about
three days after that you burn your
mouth off can I keep this
thank you alright really bitter poison
it oh the toxic waste really oh well
next please much sweating I thought she
said I got the drains of dog poo woman
sneezes causing snot to cover the camera
that would be amazing
a pigeon flies into the woman's face
I'll be equally as amazing a spider
cause out from her false lash oh my god
I hope it's sea
no way what would you do how did you let
that happen how much you're cheap in
drinking you just got home for the town
I don't know how to do this one okay no
I don't I don't I just not a thing
okay it's nothing it is a thing but it's
not a thing try your best
we're in London we're going down the
street to a funky B oh and I'm gonna get
a haircut free summer so you do whatever
you want Oh
I'm sizing fury oh come on
me no you don't know dextrous enough for
that dog runs onto the ice and knocks
them both over that would that would
make my day a gaggle of geese slide
along the ice both of them fall through
the ice sheet they both look pretty
stupid so I imagine that they're gonna
fall through the ice
they also look English and nowhere in
England does it get cold enough for ice
that you can stand on does it trying us
over those oh you yeah I knew that was
gonna happen
he's so English as Rosa oh okay okay
is this what um Woody Harrelson eats in
that zombie film I've always wanted to
try one of these if this is bad I'm
gonna be so disappointed
oh it's a bit damp though if you kept
this looks moving in don't what is that
oh gosh you can go wrong with a jaffa
cake if your land doesn't offer you
jaffa cakes achieved in your name
I mean jaffa cakes for me jaffa cakes
again win that one for me whatever you
like cheese and that much I'm not really
that much of a fan of cheese let's
definitely skip that one I always wonder
who was the first person that went yeah
I'll just try that bit of moldy cheese
who was the first person that thought
that was all right you know all right
looks like a good idea
oh my
I'm hoping that snake turns around and
bites him what's he doing dragging that
snake leave it be man
let's slither off you have to be an
idiot to get killed by a Python I'm
sorry to anyone who's got killed by a
Python but you have to be a proper idiot
they're not poisonous they're not quick
you literally have to be lying still for
a Python to kill you so this man I hope
it gets him it turns out that the snake
tail it's attached to a person well then
that would be a good reason to pull on
the pipe that would actually be if he's
trying to save another human being fair
enough be the snake angrily launches at
the man I hope so see the snake is
eating a kangaroo I'm conflicted there
because I do like kangaroos but then it
is the circle of life and we shouldn't
be interfering with the circle of life
that would be wrong and like imagine if
David Attenborough saved the zebra every
time then the Lions would die right
please bite him please buy him oh yeah
serves you right mate
they look either on Safari you're not
supposed to touch the animal I like how
he has a rag around the end of the snake
like that's the dangerous part it is
easy
[Applause]
I don't know like octopus no dolphins oh
you know what a good impression that I
used too freaked my mom out when I was
young like oh these aren't alcoholic
drinks are they oh it is root beer oh my
god that's disgusting
what is root beer now I know I mean that
tastes really good actually
this is death juice this is essentially
what this is kids be wary because you
can drink a lot of it but you will die
amazingly it's gonna have to be this
disgusting what's she doing a woman gets
lifted into the bin a squirrel leaps out
from inside the bin I think that's
what's gonna happen a cloud of smoke
puffs out from the bin well we've seen
the bit open it's got to be the squirrel
all right let's have a look I hope
there's a squirrel in there and she
fries it yeah oh we had squirrels once
in my roof at my parents house and we
didn't save them but we we would trap
them in these traps and then we would
take them to Richmond Park to to free
them and squirrels are scary man when
they're in that cage it was like
bouncing around going mental it's like
screaming and you know you're holding it
you're trying to like open it and I just
thought the school's gonna run out and
rip my face off and I would
work again right next or a trip to my
dentist
ah well Gregg's is already done
cuz it's from Craig's well that's a
Krispy Kreme doughnut though isn't it
let's go like that what's this sausage
rolls well I know what I should roll
tastes like lads this wins I used to
order great everyday when I was when I
was at secondary school there was one
outside my bus stop when I used to the
ice buns every day it is not viable yeah
this is the laughable everyone always
finish me about my thanks right I am
snap Wars oh it's brilliant
highest performing video actually think
it is you know I'll be right okay so
what what is I don't